eine print kollegin schrieb letztens
wladimir putin wird strategisch
verlieren selbst wenn er die ukraine
militärisch besiegen sollte denn gegen
ökonomische realitäten lässt sich kein
krieg führen russland ist arm und wird
durch die invasion noch ärmer über
wirtschaftliche kosten und mehr möchte
ich jetzt mit dem militär ökonom markus
kolb sprechen einen schirm guten morgen
herr kolb
direkt daran anschließen ich habe acht
millionen fragen deswegen komme ich
direkt zur sache auch sie sagen russland
begehrt ökonomischen selbstmord warum
ja ich kann das eigentlich unterstützen
die äußerungen die sie gerade zitiert
haben die russische wirtschaft
entwickelt sich im moment zurück wir
sehen russland in eine schwere rezession
fallen wir sehen eine zunehmende
migration der gut ausgebildete
mittelschicht aus russland hinaus wir
werden große probleme bekommen mit den
russischen unternehmensanleihen mit dem
russischen bank bilanzen es ist
eigentlich sehr traurig die russische
wirtschaft war eigentlich auf einem sehr
stabilen wachstumskurs noch letztes jahr
ist auch gut durch die pandemie gekommen
aber dieser krieg ist ist ökonomisch
völlig unsinnig und so leid mir das tut
der die russische zivilbevölkerung wird
am stärksten darunter zu leiden der
westen hat ja putins krieg kasse
blockiert indem die russische
zentralbank vom
weltfinanzsystem abgekoppelt wurde aber
mit ich sag mal unseren gas und
ölimporten aus russland finanzieren wir
den russischen überfall auf die ukraine
das ist jedenfalls die kritik an
deutschland ist diese kritik eigentlich
wirklich berechtigt nein ich sehe das
überhaupt nicht so das ist ein argument
dass sie von westlichen kommentatoren
sehr viel hören aber man muss eines ganz
klar sehen die russische
rüstungsindustrie ist autark sowohl was
die technologie angeht die arbeitskräfte
die rohstoffe das hängt nicht ab vom öl
und gasgeschäft auch nicht von
westlichen genießen man muss auch sinn
von den russischen öl fördermengen also
von den elf millionen barrel die
russland fordert pro tag gehen drei
millionen in den russischen
eigenverbrauch und da sind auch die
streitkräfte enthalten das heißt also
selbst wenn der westen komplett
russisches öl und russisches gas
boykottieren würde dann würde diese
eigenproduktion weiterlaufen und die
russischen truppen werden versorgt von
horst ist also von dem staatsunternehmen
diese zahlung bin in rubel fakturiert
das ist völlig unabhängig von
ausländischen währungen aber ich muss
noch mal nachfragen putin hat doch nur
die dd wesen die täglich nach russland
strömen bei wir gas und öl importieren
und da fließen ja millionen
das stimmt so nicht ganz also er hat
schon noch wie soll ich sagen eine
kleine reserve nämlich dem den
russischen nationalen wohlfahrtsfonds
von etwa 200 milliarden und es stimmt
zwar schon dass die verkäufe von öl und
gas nach wie vor die diesen liefern aber
russland hat jetzt auch viele viele
probleme gleichzeitig zu lösen und muss
die devisen dafür einsetzen also sprich
die die russische wirtschaft entwickelt
sich immer mehr zurück aber sie dürfen
sich nicht vorstellen dass das von heute
auf morgen geschieht ist es eher also
ein langsamer kontinuierlicher
verfallsprozess und deswegen darf man
sich nicht der illusion hingeben dass
russland jetzt quasi von heute auf
morgen implodiert es ist mehr so ein
langsamer verfall aber dass das kann
durchaus noch einige wochen bis monate
dauern ist sie resultat ist aber noch
mal das heißt nicht dass der krieg
deswegen aufhören mir selbst in russland
ökonomisch zusammen bricht diese
militärische maschinerie die kann
weiterlaufen jetzt total interessant
putins entscheidung russisches erdgas
nur noch gegen rubel für unfreundliche
starten ist das jetzt ist das clever
oder ist das ein zeichen von schwäche
nein also ich würde mich da immer
korrespondentin anschließend das ist es
ist eigentlich ein bluff
zentralbanken machen so etwas ganz gerne
mal das verbale intervention also das
beste beispiel wäre draghi damals in 20
12 also gesagt hat whatever it takes und
damit den euro kurs stabilisiert hat sie
sehen das heute am devisenmarkt dass der
hohe kurs sich ein wenig stabilisiert
aufgrund dieser äußerung weil man sagt
na ja angenommen es wäre wirklich so
dann müssten sich ja die westlichen
unternehmen die russisches öl
importieren oder auch gar importieren
die müssen sich ja rubel beschaffen also
sie am devisenmarkt kaufen und dafür
euro oder dollar verkaufen und das
werden sie natürlich am größten onshore
markt für rubel thonet er befindet sich
in moskau hat sich dass ihre
korrespondenz ist völlig richtig gesagt
es ist wäre eine umgehung der sanktionen
weil jede hobel transaktion endet
letztlich bei der bei der russischen
zentralbank
es ist es ist nett gedacht
aber sie müssen auch sehen die
lieferverträge die laufende teilweise
über zehn bis 15 jahre die sind in
dollar und euro verhandelt wenn er das
wirklich durchsetzen wollte dann müsste
er vertragsbrüchig werden oder eben die
lieferverträge neu verhandeln ich kann
mir nicht vorstellen wie das
funktionieren sollte ich habe noch eine
ganz schnelle kurze frage mit der bitte
um kurze antwort die rolle chinas kann
das land so eine art wirtschaftlicher
lebensversicherung werden für russland
nein dafür ist der große chinesische
außenhandel zu unbedeutend ich denke im
gegenteil china wird waren bis russland
kurz vor dem ökonomischen zusammenbruch
steht und dann billig die r setzt auf
kampf dann vielen herzlichen dank für
diese wirklich sehr interessanten
informationen einordnung und ihnen alles
gute danke schön ihn auch dankeschön